hello good morning everyone
I hope you're ready because my talk is
gonna be a really big change of context
as pace as well as content I'm gonna be
talking about a lot more technical stuff
there's gonna be a lot of code I'm
specifically going to talk about the
document side of SVG so over a lot over
the last three years I've been working a
lot with SVG and I've been seeing a lot
of developers use SVG a lot more than
they used to do before which is amazing
but I've been seeing them like they're
there's usually to focus on two specific
things and SVG either using them oh
there's a dog in here
use them using them either to display
small icons and illustrations or to
animate icons and illustrations or even
bigger stuff but usually either
displaying simple static images or
animating them but SVG because of its
nature as both an image format and the
document format it can do a lot more
than that and the document side of SVG
is not usually touched a lot I'm not
sure if it's because developers don't
know of what's possible with SVG or
maybe they haven't had the time to look
into it so I'm going to go over just
some of the things that you can do with
SVG hopefully they will be able to
inspire you to do more actually did you
know that SVG is so powerful that and
dr. whose season 7 episode 2 missiles
are being guided by the power of SVG
that's pretty cool huh now seriously
though there is so much that you can do
and I'm going to be only be gonna be
covering like four or five things I'm
gonna be starting with cropping scaling
and preserving aspect ratio using using
SVG now in particular I'm gonna be
showing you how you can use SVG SVG can
be used to replace certain CSS features
when the browser support for those
features is not really that good now
this is not an SVG versus CSS thing
these two work fantastically together
but there are certain things that we can
do with with CSS that were actually
imported from SVG and browser support
for those features is not really that
good yet so in the meantime you can use
SVG as long as you know about how those
things work in SVG now when we talk
about cropping scaling and preserving
aspect ratio SVG there
two attributes in particular that we
usually talk about that they will do all
of this work for us the SVG view box
what I call or what I like to call the
SVG superpowers and the SVG preserve
aspect ratio attribute I like to call
the cousin of the view box or the best
friend because they do amazing things
together now these two are the most
powerful and possibly less or underused
attributes of SVG now before we get into
how these two work together and how
we're going to use them
I want to go we need to be able to
differentiate between the SVG view box
and the SVG view port because there are
two different concepts now the sq2 view
port is the viewing area of the SVG you
can think of it as a window through
which you see an inset a certain scene
just like a regular window this the
scene could be visible in its entirety
or just partially within that window now
the size of that window every window has
a finite size the finite size of this
window is determined by the width and
height attributes on the route SVG
element for example in this SVG here the
black borders in this example are the
borders of the SVG and they are defined
using the width and height attributes on
the SVG element and they establish what
is known as the viewport of the SVG the
viewport is what the browser uses to
determine how the SVG behaves in the
context of the page just like any other
HTML element that has a width and a
height the browser uses those dimensions
in order to layout the entire page and
if you change the width and height of an
HTML element it's going to affect the
entire layout and there's going to be
repainting and we layout this is the
kind of width and height that SVG also
has and just like HTML elements the
width and the height establish a
coordinate system on the SVG that
coordinate system is called the initial
coordinate system but this coordinate
system is not what it may seem at first
so what you see here the cat inside of
the borders the browser does not use the
initial coordinate system of the SVG of
the viewport to draw the SVG on the
canvas because conceptually the canvas
is infinite in both dimensions so just a
quickly finishing the canvas is the
space or the area where the SVG content
is drawn conceptually it's infinite in
both dimensions however it is rendered
on the screen relative to a finite
region known as the viewport our
rectangle
areas of the SVG that lie beyond the
boundaries of the viewport are clipped
off and not visible now I like to think
about SVG is in the sense as being
similar to Google Maps so you have this
small finite area just like an iframe
you see only part of that map but if you
drag that map around in the background
you can see a lot more so whenever I
think about SVG and I have to think
about viewport versus canvas I think
about it literally as two layers there's
the front layer just like a stencil with
a small rectangle and then there's the
back layer where all of my drawing is
taking place now in order for the
browser to be able to draw on that
infinite canvas that needs a coordinate
system and because it does not use the
coordinate system of the SVG width and
height it's going to need another
coordinate system so yes we have two
coordinate systems and SVG the
coordinate system created inside of the
SVG on the canvas is created using the
SVG view box that's what the view box is
for so we have the U port which is the
window width and height and we have the
view box which is the coordinate system
on the canvas the coordinate system on
the canvas has a different name so we
had initial initial chord in a system on
the viewport I still like there's I
think you're doing this for three years
and I still have to work viewport versus
view box initial coordinate system
versus the user coordinate system you're
rarely going to be using those names
anyway so it's usually viewport versus
view box now the viewport takes four
numerical numerical values the first
made up four values the first to
determine determine the coordinates of
the top left corner of the of the
coordinate system so initially basically
where the coordinate system starts and
then you have the the width and the
height of the coordinate system because
even though the canvas is infinite the
coordinate system has to be finite now
together these values make up the
coordinate system and they are initially
initially identical to the initial
coordinate system so when you create an
SVG in Illustrator for example and you
export that SVG you're going to find
that the view box the width and the
height on the view box are going to be
identical and equal to the width on the
height on the SVG
this is the default state but things
start to get a little bit confusing and
too exciting when you start changing
these values and this is where I'm going
to be using
my different accordant Gordian system
demo bigger so I create it just I'm
gonna make them identical at first so
the gray coordinate system that you see
here is the coordinate system
established on the SVG so the SVG is 800
pixels wide by 600 pixels high and
initially the coordinate system on the
canvas which is the view box is
identical this is what we have here okay
now by changing the values I created
this demo three years ago when I was
first getting into SVG I was started
changing the values of the view box
unexpected things happened I banged my
head against the wall for two weeks
before I got finally to the aha moment
where I figure out the difference
between them and the only reason I was
able to do it is because I created this
to visualize them otherwise it would
have been really difficult so view box
viewport there initially the same but
you can change the value of the width
and the height of the view box inside so
if you make it bigger the aspect ratio
of the view box inside of the SVG is
different now but by default the browser
is going to the browser Maps the the
user the view box coordinate system to
the viewport coordinate system so by
default even no matter how big the view
box becomes it's going to be contained
inside of the viewport contained or not
contained that depends you can also
control that say you also want to change
this now the first thing you may have
noticed is by changing the values of the
view box by making them bigger you're
scaling the contents of the SVG down if
you make it smaller you can scale the
contents of the SVG up so this is one of
the ways that you can manipulate SVG is
using the view box now the MINIX and min
y the x and y are outside the scope of
the structure I'm gonna be not going
over them
so right now assume that you have some
content inside of the SVG the view box
has a different aspect ratio from the
SVG so you have some white space at the
top white space at the bottom that's
fine just like background images and CSS
you are able in SVG you can tell the
browser if you want the entire view box
to be
ximenos if you want the entire view
books to be contained inside the
viewport or if you wanted to cover the
entire viewport area background images
in CSS if you set the background size to
contain you're gonna get this result if
the background of the of the element has
a different aspect ratio from the
element itself you can tell the browser
to either make it can't be contained
inside of the element which means that
you will get some white space on top on
and on the bottom or left and right or
you can tell the browser that you want
it to scale it up as much as possible to
cover the entire background area even if
that means cropping out some parts of
the image now you can do exactly the
same thing with SVG if you use the
preserve aspect ratio attribute now this
is what I have here keep in mind that
this drawing here you could have
anything on the view box I just happen
to have a parrot here because I'm a bird
person I don't like I don't have much
against cats but I'm a bird person so I
have a parrot here and I have a lot of
white space here but you can imagine an
entire SVG scene or illustration now if
I change the value of the preserve
aspect ratio from meet which is the same
as contained in CSS to slice which is
the same as cover I get this I don't
have any white space and that at the top
and the bottom so this is the view box
where the view box starts now at the top
but what's happening here is the view
box via canvas has been scaled up as
much as possible to cover the entire
viewport area and it happens to be white
in my case but you know it has been
scaled up initially it is centered just
like the background position Center
Center you can change the position of
that image as well for example sometimes
you position a background image in CSS
by saying top left so it starts at the
top left corner you can do that as well
using x-men women it's the similar to
top left you can get this you can also
the default value is x-men Twyman which
is the center you're centering it this
way you can also choose xmax ymax so now
I'm showing the bottom right area of my
canvas inside of the viewport
now imagine using this so suppose you
have an image here any kind of image
that has a different aspect ratio from
the container of that image and you want
to be able to crop that image and
position it inside of that container any
way you want this is possible with SPG
so let's get back to no not yeah that's
it
so as you can imagine just to recap
because of our ability to use and
manipulate the under coordinate system
we are able to create all kinds of great
effects and techniques to do a myriad of
things in SVG one of these things is
cropping and preserving aspect ratio of
non SVG images so CSS currently does
that we currently have the object fit
and object position properties in CSS
using object fit you can the contents of
an image or a video for example could be
also video can be set to scale up and
down shrink or stretch as necessary to
fit into the width and the height you
specify so further for example suppose
that you have an avatar image all of the
avatar images need to be square ok and
you have a CMS like WordPress and you're
allowing your authors to upload upload
images of their own they don't upload a
square image so you're going to have to
be able to crop that image and scale it
and put it inside of that square area
that you have this is possible in CSS
using objects with an object position
object position tells you how you can
position the image and object fit does
something like this so I have an image
here again a doc and I have a square so
you can tell the browser if you want the
image to be fit inside of the square
without preserving the aspect ratio so
it kind of shrinks horizontally here you
can tell it that you want it to be
contained which creates white space at
the top at the top and bottom you can
tell it to cover it which is the most
used value so it covers the entire
square area and crops out any extras and
it's going to be centered by by default
none means that it's not going to be
doing any scaling or stretching at all
and scale down is very similar to
contain with very minor minor
differences this is pretty cool so using
just one line of CSS you can allow your
users to upload any kind of images that
they want while preserving the aspect
ratio and your designs but the browser
support is not really good and as usual
our main problem is Internet Explorer
even a message currently doesn't support
it but it's coming in this upcoming edge
version so suppose that you do still
need us to provide support for IE so you
will probably want to look for a
different solution so you can either use
this as an enhancement if you don't care
about IE if you can start supporting
only the
versions of all browsers I do have
clients who do that by the way which is
amazing means 2017
so you can check the port for object
fill by using the supports rule you like
you only apply the CSS styling of the
images if the object property is
supported which is pretty cool but if
you want to support older browsers you
may come up with a solution I think a
lot of developers already do this on the
back end so they do all of the cropping
on the back end before sending the
cropped image image to the front end but
you don't even need to do that using
this small SVG snippet you can do
exactly that so instead of embedding can
you see the code so some of you are
doing this some are just some are this
so using I'm gonna go through the code
shortly using the snippet you can
instead of embedding an image tag on
your page you would be embedding an SVG
okay the SVG has a width and a height a
view box
it always has a view box and it has a
preserve aspect ratio usually you can
omit the preserve aspect ratio and let
the browser handle everything but if
you're going to be doing something like
this you want it to be there and you
want to change the value now inside of
the SVG you have an image tag I am a GE
the SVG the XML image tag you link to
the user uploaded image inside of the
image tag okay the width and the height
of the image are set to be 100% by 100%
which means that they will scale up to
fill the entire view books not the
viewport okay
the SVG width and height determined the
viewport so which is going to be for
example a square on your page the image
may not be square so you have some white
space inside of the SVG the view box
value is going to be 0 0 image X and
image Y at the image X and image Y are
going to be the width and the height of
the user uploaded image so try to
imagine it you have s Square and you
have which is the SVG and you have an
image inside of the SVG with a different
aspect ratio the view box has the same
dimensions as that image so we get the
exact same thing we got earlier the
white space on top and on the bottom
okay so in this case what's happening
here is you've used s we just as the
regular container for your
jpg image or whatever PNG image or
Ruster image okay it's not you're not
using SVG as an image format anymore
using it as dog meat just like a div and
and an HTML it's just a wrapper here now
using the preserve aspect ratio you can
specify the alignment if you wanted to
be contained if you wanted to be covered
if you want to move it inside of it
cropping scaling everything happens like
this so an example would be the width
and height of the SVG could be 140
pixels the user uploads an 800 by 500
pixels image you link to that image and
then all of the work is done in the
preserve aspect ratio you probably if
you want to do the kind of cropping that
CSS does by default most of the time it
would be preserved aspect ratio slice
which is similar to cover and eczema
Twyman so the image is cropped to a
square without using a single line of
CSS and with browser support that go
away that goes way back are you gonna
see it shortly this code is missing
something so you've replaced an image
tag with an SVG but it's missing
something what is it say out loud
yeah the alt tag you should never serve
an image without an alt tag even if the
image is just decoration keep the alt
tag empty as long as you keep it there
okay so we don't have any alt tags on
image elements inside of SVG but we do
have an alternative we have the title
element inside of the SVG the title
element is similar to an alt tag so you
can give your image a title you should
always include a title for all of your
SVG images if you can or if they are not
simply just a creation you can even add
the desk element which is short for
description so if you I want to add the
title and a description to your image
you can add that and this snippet here
gives you all kinds of scaling and
preserving aspect ratios in HTML all the
way back to IE 9 because i 8 does not
support SVG's know CSS required now
suppose you've cropped your image to
square dimensions the next step is to
make it responsive okay the maintaining
aspect ratio and CSS while making the
image image fluid is not very easy so if
the browser width if the if the width of
the image is 100% how do you tell the
browser that you want
the height of the image to always be
equal to the width of the image now in
the future and future CSS specifications
there there will be away so tab Atkins
told me that they will be specking out
something so that we will be able to
preserve aspect ratio CSS sometime soon
but right now we cannot do that so this
is particularly a problem for inline SVG
s or SVG is embedded using an iframe by
default the default size for replaced
elements in CSS is 300 pixels by 150
pixels diff replaced elements are
elements like an iframe where the size
of the item is not really defined by the
iframe itself its defined by the
contents and because you don't really
know the size of the contents the
browser doesn't know the size of the
iframe and it's going to give it in that
case a default size of 350 pixels by 150
pixels an inline SVG if the SVD doesn't
contain any content and it doesn't have
any dimensions or anything if you've
ever maybe created an SVG sprite the SVG
sprite contains symbols that are not
displayed on the page maybe some of you
may have run into this where you get
some empty white area on the page and
you don't really know where where that
came from
it's because of that SVG is a replaced
element and the browser is going to be
giving it 350 pixels by 150 pixels
unless you tell it otherwise now when
you embed an SVG in line it's going to
be as long as it has a view box it's
going to scale as you expect it to and
all of the browser's expect and accept
and ie so what II's gonna do it's gonna
make the width of the SVG scale as you
would want it to scale but it's gonna
fix the height 150 pixels because it's
done so in order to fix that and in
order to preserve aspect ratio for
anything essentially in CSS you need a
technique which is commonly commonly
known as the padding hack so I'm gonna
go over how it works I'm gonna show you
an example so to make an SVG responsive
with a preserve aspect ratio first you
wrap the SVG in a container now I want
you to remember the last thing that we
did okay so we have an image or an SVG
with a specific aspect ratio and that
SVG contains an image a raster image
inside of it with a different aspect
ratio now what you need to do is you
need to make sure that the SVG scales up
and down while maintaining the aspect
ratio of the image inside of it
so in order to do that you wrap the SVG
in a container you collapse the
containers height you give it any width
value that you want it could be 100
percent 70 percent 50 percent whatever
and then you apply the padding top as
Dennis mentioned something at the
beginning of his talk when you set the
padding in CSS using percentage values
it's going to be relative to the width
of the element not the height so even if
you say padding top 50% padding top is
going to be set 50% of the width of the
element not 50% of the height so if
suppose you've collapsed the height of
the container it doesn't have a height
anymore its height zero and then you
apply a top padding to that element so
you're extending expanding the height
again but the height this time is
created by the padding and the padding
is set and percentages which is relative
to the width so you have the height that
is relative to the width and you've
established an aspect ratio so we want
our container here to have the same
aspect ratio as the SVG view box which
is the image inside of it I know this is
a little bit too much but it's it's
really cool so how do you determine the
value of the padding top it's with this
formula so you get the aspect ratio of
the SVG view bucks in this case as good
you hide over SVG width and then you
multiply it by this value all right so
you have SVG contained inside of a
container the SVG is still there you've
collapsed the height of the container
okay so now the SVG is hanging outside
of it and then you've added a padding to
the container cool but the SVG has been
pushed down now so in order to put it
back into the container you're going to
need to be using absolute positioning so
you have to start by creating an aspect
for creating a positioning context on
the container by using position:relative
and then you position the SVG absolutely
inside of the container and you've
established an aspect ratio responsively
and this is what it looks like
this is a video it should work yeah so I
have an SVG here oh I don't see it here
if I change the preserve aspect ratio
value now I've cropped the image inside
of it so this is one of the things you
can do I don't see the cursor now you
can also change the aspect ratio of the
entire viewport and it's responsive no
matter what the aspect ratio of the SVG
is going to be fully fluid and
responsive
another thing you can do with SPG so the
first section recovered how SVG is used
just as a mere container for raster
images in order to crop scale and
manipulate them any way you want by
preserving with while also preserving
aspect ratio now JPEGs have better
compression rate ratios than PNG is for
photographic data JPEGs generally
speaking they always have smaller file
sizes than PNG s now what if you could
get the compression ratio of a JPEG
while serving a PNG image so you would
serve a PNG image with transparency but
you would get the compression ratio of
the JPEG surprise-surprise you can do
that using using SVG now again our SVG
will serve as a mere container for a
bitmap image and then we'll use some SVG
magic which aks SVG masks to get the
transparency of the PNG while serving
the JPEG now the idea behind this
technique is to use an SVG mask to clip
out the areas of the JPEG that you do
not want to see that you want to be
transparent so we end up serving a JPEG
with simulated alpha channels thus
combining the transparency of a PNG with
the compression rate of a JPEG for
example suppose we have the following
image here the image on the left is what
we want to display it is a PNG image
with another bird is out of it so we
start with a jpg JPEG version of the
image in the middle it doesn't have any
transparent areas and then you create a
mask illuminance mask in this case to
mask out the areas of the end of the
JPEG image that you do not want okay so
the luminance mask means that the
luminance areas of the mask represent
the areas of the SVG that you that you
want to keep so the white area here is
the DOE which we want to keep and
everything in black
when this mask is applied to the image
in the middle we're going to get the
result over there using SVG so we use
SVG to apply the mask so you have an SVG
you have a depths element depths element
is short for definitions anything you
put inside of a depth element in SVG is
not going to be rendered on the page
you're literally just defining templates
that you want to be used or applied
somewhere else so inside of the Deaf's
element i create a mask that mask is
actually an image so you're using an
image
as a mosque straight forward so we have
the pigeon mosque we're referencing it
here and then you embed your JPEG image
with a really cool compression rates and
you apply the mask to it at the bottom I
hope it's visible I hope you can see it
and the SVG the mask and the image
element have the same dimensions because
it's the same image and this is all you
need you're serving a JPEG and a JPEG so
will you get the compression of the JPEG
and you're making it transparent using
SVG masks now one of the most frequent
questions that I get here is how does
this work with responsive images so if I
only serve the 1x or 2x versions of the
image what if I want to serve 1 X 2 X 3
X depending on the resolution of the
image I've not tried that yet but I
imagine it could use a foreign object so
a foreign object is an element in SVG
which tells the XML parser that the
content inside of me is not really XML
so you could use picture and source that
I imagine I haven't tested it yet so but
you could use maybe picture source set
all kinds of HTML stuff inside of the
SVG so you would replace the image
element here with a foreign object that
contains picture and source set and you
would still apply the mask to it and you
get the compression that you want now
just like you can optimize raster image
delivery with SVG can also optimize SVG
delivery with SVG so I was I worked on
the new Smashing Magazine redesign which
I don't know one well I think it will
get public soon but we've been saying
some for like a year so I'm not really
sure you should ask Vitaly one of the
things that we had in the new magazine
is we have these three new membership
plans ok
I built the front and so I had to embed
all of these things now for every
membership plan on the membership page
we have a title and name for each
membership type one of them a supporter
member
I feel smashing they have changed these
illustrations I've also changed but the
technique behind them is still the same
plus the cute little illustration is
really nice
so one thing there are a couple of
important things to note here the text
inside of these images or no first of
all these images are used
instead of the headings so you have a
section that describes the supporter
plan but that section does not have a
title so when it comes to accessibility
or
reading in general you need a title for
that section right the title is inside
of the image which means that the text
inside of this image needs to be
selectable searchable and accessible now
there are a couple of things when you
when you have an SVG even though this is
a perfect candidate for SVG you need to
first test that SVG is actually a good
candidate for the image so at first when
I saw these illustrations they have a
lot of details I imagine that well when
an SVG contains a lot of effects a lot
of details a lot of information the file
size of the SVG can get so big that
you're better off using a PNG instead so
at first I thought okay I need the text
to be accessible so I need as an SVG but
I need to test the performance first
luckily the SVG size was exactly the
same as the PNG size so I was good I was
able to use this I can use SVG I can
have the text inside of it the text
inside of the SVG unless you turn it
into outlines which means shapes it's
going to be searchable selectable
accessible just like HTML text users can
select it with the mouse SEO all kinds
of stuff comes with it by default so
after deciding I was going to go with
SVG I had to start decide to think about
what kind of embedding technique am I am
I going to use we have seven ways to
embed SVG is on a page which one should
you use the the answer to that question
is always it depends it depends it
depends so since I want the text to be
searchable selectable accessible and I
want to be able to apply the font face
Miha in this case to that text the easy
there are two ways you can do that first
of all you can have the SVG be external
reference that SVG externally but in
that case you would have to go into the
SVG define the font face there and then
apply to the text which means that you
would have to maintain two sets of
styles in the main CSS and in the SVG I
didn't want that so I try to only have
one source of truth as much as possible
so I figured I could do it inline if I
am betty's SVG's inline I will get all
the benefits and I will go into the main
stylesheet I will apply the front face
to this text and it works it does work
but I couldn't really like imagine
having to embed this inline in your HTML
it's not done yet not yet this is only
one of them not all three of them
every one of those illustrations was so
huge so I didn't want to embed the SVG
externally I didn't I wasn't able I
wasn't going to embed it and line like
this so I needed to come up with a
better solution and that is when I
started thinking I mean I can go into
the SVG and I can change the code inside
of it so I thought why don't I get the
benefits of SVG text also serve the
benefits of an SVG illustration but
separate them so I thought I could
separate the illustration from the text
inside of it and see how that works so I
ended up doing something like this
I had an inline SVG and the text I went
into each one of those illustrations and
I removed the text from them okay so
right now I'm referencing an SVG
inside of an inline SVG I'm getting HTTP
cache I mean I'm getting caching there's
gonna be an extra HTTP request but
that's okay the file size wasn't really
big and we're gonna be able to cache the
image which is really good but the image
does not now have any text so I thought
I could just add the text in line and
you position the text because both the
illustration and the text here are part
of the same SVG so you have an SVG that
contains an SVG and that also contains a
piece of text what you're left with in
this case is to just position the text
on the illustration in a way that gives
you the result that you initially had so
then if you want to go on and style the
text apply a font face apply a full
color make it bold style that you can do
that from the main see a style sheet
without having to maintain to like the
SVG in one place and the page and
another page but I have something wrong
here and it's intentional I didn't know
it when I bothe the site but later I did
but
I keep it on the slide intentionally so
supporter is written all caps inside of
the HTML this is not good screen errors
are going to read this out loud as su
ppor ter and you don't want them to do
that so FYI always make sure that your
text is set in regular caps inside of
your HTML and if you want to make it all
caps do that and CSS conditional
processing now you can again use SVG to
handle SVG's or other SVG's or you can
use SVG to serve SVG while also
providing non SVG as a fallback and this
is like okay the SVG document structure
specification defines elements and
attributes family the switch element
with three attributes that give us the
ability to specify alternate viewing
depending on the capable a blah blah
which essentially means that it checks
if the browser is going to if it has
support for SVG if it does its you serve
a specific thing and if it does not it
gives you the ability to to provide
another thing as an alternative viewing
experience now the three attributes on
the switch element serve as sort of an
if statement or conditions if the
conditions are met then the switch
statement is true and the first element
inside of the switch statement is going
to be rendered so this is an example
here suppose you have a spreadsheet that
contains a set of icons every icon is
defined inside of a symbol element you
have a spreadsheet
essentially this is an inline SVG inside
of an SVG I have the switch element
which is like switch case in Java Script
or as else the first element is that of
the switch element is the use use is
referencing some icon Twitter
so it's an SVG icon okay and it's the
first element inside of the SVG okay the
second element is a foreign object which
I mentioned before the foreign object
means that everything inside of this
area this foreign object is not XML so
the foreign object allows you to embed
none non SVG inside of an SVG okay
inside of the foreign object I have an
empty div which will serve as a fallback
the that div is going to have a
background which is the icon but as an
SVG as a PNG format so what happens here
is if the browser supports SVG it's
going to come to the switch statement
it knows SVG so it's going to render the
first element inside of it which is our
SVG icon if a browser does not support
SVG is going to ignore the first line
it's going to a can't see my mouse
you can't know it's going to ignore the
first SVG root element it's going to
ignore the switch because it doesn't
know what it is it's going to ignore
they use because it doesn't know what it
is it's going to ignore for an object so
this is just the parser going through
the elements it ignores for an object
and then it comes to at the hey I do
know HTML so I am going to render this
div and this div happens to be an empty
div with a PNG background image which is
our fallback for the SVG icon
now some browsers that are that do
support SVG are going to download both
adventures or request both images
they're going to show the SVG icon but
they're also going to request the PNG
which is something you do not want so in
order to prevent that you can add
another SVG to the same page both of
them are in line
now in the second SVG you hide the
background image in the first SVG any
Styles in the first SVG will affect the
elements in the second and vice versa
pretty cool there's a lot of SVG
inception but it's really like and I
know I'm going fast but I don't want to
be taking up all of your lunch break or
your coffee break this is also you also
have the same problem if you use an
object to display and as we an SVG
object is my absolute favorite
SVG embedding technique because it
allows you to script the SVG using
JavaScript animates a style it you get
the caching you get the performance and
everything so between the opening and
closing object tags you provide the full
back for the SVG your reference the SVG
and the object type attribute all good
if a browser supports SVG is going to
display that if a browser does not
support SVG or if the SVG fails to load
if it doesn't find the SVG it's going to
go into the object tag the contents of
that and it's going to use the content
inside of it as a fallback for the SVG
now you can also again use an empty div
with a background image but make sure
that you hide that as well to prevent
any multiple downloads now SVG can do
more and I'm going to show these
examples again live
one of the things that one of my
attendees at frontiers showed me was
this map here so they have this history
map for the history of Syria this map
the actual map is an image a raster
image inside of the this viewport which
is an SVG so you have an SVG container
an SVG document and you're referencing
an image inside of it and these paths
here these circles like if you go to the
places and you want to highlight stuff
you can do that all this using
javascript and then you can use even a
little bit more of the SPG features to
do this like each one of these colored
areas as a path that has a fill color
and then some of them I think it's
already here somewhere no but one of the
things that they have here is there you
can also use a blur on each one of these
so it's like you're doing heat mapping
so you would have a path a colored path
applied apply a blur to that so you get
some sort of heat maps which is pretty
cool but but what's even nicer is you
can do this which has been making the
rounds on Twitter for the few days so
you're using SVG here to serve JPEGs or
PNG s again but you're you're doing
you're making the experience a little
bit nicer so you're serving an outline
which is an SVG path you're serving an
outline of the actual image that you're
loading so if i refresh it again these
are SVG's and an SVG container and once
the images are lazy lazy loaded and
they're ready to be displayed you
display them inside of these SPG's which
is pretty cool and because it is really
useful someone on Twitter mu he he
created this WebP a coder that exports
traced outlines as images so you give it
your images it's going to create those
SPG outlines for you and then you can
embed it he even created other stuff
like you can you can create these
learned previews as well which is pretty
cool and my last slide is thank you
slide so thank you
[Applause]